Which Batman do people keep referencing in
"Peacemaker" and how could it tie into the
upcoming Flash movie?
Are these just jokes or are they actually
hidden secrets that only the cleverest fans
could find?
Christopher Smith is living proof that a sucker
is born every minute on the internet.
Throughout the first season of "Peacemaker,"
he reveals that Aquaman is mer-curious and
Superman loves to leap the tallest buildings
for a chance to snack on fresh butt burritos.
Of course, these are only a handful of fun
facts about the Justice League that he's scoured
the internet for, and he treats every dubious
comments section as gospel.
"You actually believe that shit?
He has an insane story for every single superhero."
The question is, how far do his conspiracy
theories reach?
It doesn't help that he came from a home where
his father was a racist and misogynist criminal
who bought into every crackpot that monetizes
the spread of misinformation and division.
While the rest of Project Butterfly has poked
holes in his supposed facts about the world,
Peacemaker still holds onto an outrageous
belief system that would make the average
person question their sanity.
The other somewhat unlikely possibility is
that these are, in fact, real facts in the
world of Peacemaker.
"I'm so f**king sick of that rumor."
"It's not a rumor."
While it's common to include Easter eggs and
comic book references in superhero shows,
John Economos' declaration to Peacemaker has
an interesting implication:
"I'd rather be with f–king Bat-Mite than
you."
"Who's Bat-Mite?"
"He's a two foot tall interdimensional imp
who stans Batman.
I'd rather be with him."
It all but confirms the existence of Bat-Mite
in the DCEU.
Fans have seen this pesky character appear
in other TV shows such as "The New Adventures
of Batman" and "Batman: The Brave and the
Bold," but this is the first time he's been
mentioned in a live-action show.
On his official Instagram account, James Gunn
confirmed that Bat-Mite is now canon, but
is he really?
If he's not actually seen, how can anyone
actually be sure he exists?
We'd better stop here before the philosophical
implications get overwhelming.
It was a brave decision to turn Auggie Smith
into the White Dragon of the DCEU.
In the context of the story and our understanding
of Peacemaker's troubled past, it was a natural
fit to turn Auggie into the white supremacist
supervillain who led his son astray with a
highly questionable upbringing.
That said, there have been multiple versions
of the White Dragon in the comics.
So even though Auggie might be dead in "Peacemaker,"
he has a legion of followers who are more
than likely to take up the mantle in the future.
Ask Peacemaker who his best friend is and
there's only one answer: Eagly.
To be fair, who wouldn't want to be BFFs with
an eagle that's capable of gouging out the
eyes of enemies with both its beak and talons?
Be that as it may, Vigilante might have something
to say about this current friendship hierarchy:
Vigilante.
"Just like an all-time classic run with my
best friend Peacemaker, my second best-friend
Eagly, my fifth best friend Adebayo."
There's no doubt in anyone's mind that Vigilante
looks up to Peacemaker and sees him as his
only friend.
Even though Peacemaker won't freely admit
it in the public, he does view Adrian Chase
as a friend — albeit a bit of an annoying
one.
That said, Vigilante has been there for him
when he's needed him the most.
He might not be the most conventional of friends,
or a rational human being, but he hasn't let
down Peacemaker yet.
Maybe, just maybe, Vigilante may finally be
acknowledged as Peacemaker's best friend one
day.
Well, probably not.
"Don't tell V, but after Eagly, you're my
BFF."
Where exactly does "Peacemaker" fit in the
DC film universe's timeline?
Judging by the events and characters, it takes
place immediately after "The Suicide Squad,"
which is considered a part of the DCEU.
In this timeline, the Batman is still Ben
Affleck's version of the Caped Crusader.
However, this doesn't quite align with something
that Auggie's neighbor says to Peacemaker
about the Dark Knight not killing.
"Batman doesn't kill people."
Because he's a pussy!"
"He's a dark creature of the knight!"
"He's a jackass!"
Recalling the events of "Batman v Superman:
Dawn of Justice," Batman didn't straight-up
murder criminals, but he didn't exactly pump
the brakes on the Batmobile to avoid crashing
into them, nor did he exercise much restraint
in the brutal beatdowns he dished out, either.
It sure looks like he kills at least a couple
of bad guys.
One possibility here is that "Peacemaker"
might actually take place after the "Flash”
movie.
The upcoming movie will feature Barry Allen
breaking the timeline and crossing the streams
of the multiverse, so in the process, he could
have brought in a new Batman who has much
cleaner hands than Batfleck.
Alternatively, we're reading too much into
what's most likely just a joke.
Make no mistake about it, Christopher Smith
is a love machine.
He's got all his love to give and all his
life to live.
However, there's a revealing moment in the
episode "Murn After Reading" that indicates
a midnight rendezvous that didn't quite finish
as expected.
As a favor to Jamil, the janitor from the
hospital where Smith was, Peacemaker speaks
to the local school in an effort to make Jamil's
child seem more popular.
Naturally, the children ask him a lot of questions,
though there's one specific query that sticks
out more than the others: A little girl holds
up her hand and asks Peacemaker if he remembers
her mom Becky Coolidge.
"I haven't seen her in like 10 years."
"I think you might be my real dad."
"What?"
It's played like a joke, but it could be an
interesting plot thread for a future storyline.
What if the little girl really is Peacemaker's
daughter?
And what if her mother is someone who could
be linked to another superhero or villain?
In the episode "Stop Dragon My Heart Around,"
it's implied that Peacemaker's sexuality is
a bit more fluid than his general demeanor
might have implied.
Series creator James Gunn himself revealed
to Empire Magazine that John Cena played a
pivotal role in shaping the character's sexuality.
Gunn said,
"John does improv all the time and he just
turned Christopher Smith into this hyper-sexualized
dude that is open to anything sexually."
Considering Peacemaker's openness to romantic
partners, there's a chance that he and Vigilante
could develop into something more in the future
as well.
The two of them share an intimate encounter
with Amber, so it isn't like they haven't
had a close encounter of the bedroom kind.
At the same time, it could go a long way to
explaining Vigilante's borderline obsession
with Smith.
What started off as a bond over violent crime
fighting could blossom into something more
special and intimate between them.
That said, the answer to this question is
"probably not" since "Peacemaker" ends with
an implied bond between Chris and Harcourt.
"Peacemaker ... What a joke."
Rick Flag's line from "The Suicide Squad"
has haunted Smith ever since he killed Task
Force X's leader.
While he might have thought he had a very
good reason for doing so at the time, it still
doesn't help ease his conscience.
Ultimately, he was simply following orders,
which is something that Amanda Waller values
more than anything else.
She wants foot soldiers, not free thinkers,
on her team.
So, could he find himself back on her team
in the future?
After all, Peacemaker killing someone is nothing
new to the Suicide Squad.
This is a team full of murderous superviallins.
Peacemaker is no saint, but neither are any
of the criminals involved in Task Force X.
Waller might still see a purpose for him,
so it's possible that she might call him up
to the main team once again somewhere down
the line.
"It's Cow or Never," the Season 1 finale of
"Peacemaker," features unexpected and epic
cameos from the Justice League.
While Wonder Woman and Superman are out of
focus and shown through the use of silhouettes,
Jason Momoa's Aquaman and Ezra Miller's Flash
actually have lines and show their faces.
However, there's one crucial member missing
from the lineup here: Batman.
The Dark Knight's existence was already confirmed
in the series, so where's he hiding during
this scene?
Did the Batmobile break down or something?
Again, this could give credence to the theory
that "Peacemaker" takes place after the "Flash"
film.
Considering the movie is set to be Batfleck's
swan song in the DCEU, there's a good chance
that the Justice League might be a member
short for a while.
No one expected Adebayo to go in front of
the world and confirm the existence of Task
Force X and what it does.
Perhaps even more shockingly, she exposes
her mother's identity and role in this program.
It's an event that's likely to have major
repercussions and could result in Waller being
removed as the puppet master of the Suicide
Squad.
Yet despite Adebayo's revelations, there's
no chance that Task Force X will be shut down;
it'll simply pop up under another guise.
This might present an opportunity for someone
new to take the reins of Task Force X and
the Suicide Squad.
Adebayo is an improbable candidate since she
exposed the whole operation, but Emilia Harcourt
could be in line for a major promotion.
Her near-fatal injuries in the season finale
may move her out of the field and into an
internal role.
Perhaps a season 2 of "Peacemaker" could address
who takes over the vacancy at Task Force X.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
comic book shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.